Media malfeasance is out of control
president Trump moves to man bump stocks
and we examine the other gun proposals
are on the table talk about all of it
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
all righty so we have a lot to get to
today the media had just been utterly
irresponsible in their coverage of the
entire parkland situation they are
obviously pushing for gun control there
are no many specific proposals but
they're pushing as hard as humanly
possible for gun control nonetheless I
wanna talk about all of that including a
smear by the huffington post against me
personally a bunch of other smears
against people who are pro-gun rights
across the board and I want to talk a
little bit about some people on the
right who have made fools of themselves
over the last couple of days but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at legacy box so if you are
interested in preserving your family's
memories which everyone should be legacy
box is the way to do it I mean when as
you get older especially how kids one of
the things that you spend a lot of time
thinking about is I wish I could
remember when that happened and that's
why you take all those pictures right
but then those pictures go into storage
maybe you printed them out and you stuck
them in the garage somewhere all the
stuff from when you were kids certainly
is like that all the stuff from when
your parents were kids absolutely is
like that they're all on eight
millimeter or on old film well that's
what legacy boxes for so legacy box
sends a box to your house you take all
of those materials you label you put a
shipping label on each of them and put a
little bar code on each of them you take
all of that you send it back to legacy
box and they take all of those materials
and they put it on an easy-to-access
thumb drive or on a DVD for you so that
you have access to the stuff at all
times and you've just boiled down boxes
and boxes of material into something you
can carry around on a keychain it is a
fantastic fantastic service and a deeply
important one because you don't want to
lose those memories it's never too early
to start spring cleaning too so if you
want to make sure that you've cleaned
out your garage this is a good way to
start you get the originals back and a
couple of leaks with everything on a DVD
or thumb drive ready to enjoy share and
relive over 350,000 families have
trusted legacy box and right now for a
limited time you can say 40% at legacy
box comm slash Ben that's legacy box
comm slash spending at 40% off and again
you can get it started for 45 bucks
right now at legacy box comm slash been
fantastic fantastic service I've used it
my family has used it you should do it
for a parent she'd do it for a loved one
shooter for yourself and it's just a
great way to preserve all those memories
that otherwise will be lost so go to
legacy box comm slash Ben couldn't
endorse this service more highly legacy
box comm slash Ben also so that they
know that we sent you an to get that
forty percent off and again the packages
start at just $45 all right so I was
gonna start today by discussing all of
the various go
proposals that are on the table but
instead the media have forced me to
discuss their absolute malfeasance
throughout this entire debacle after the
tragedy and the and the evil horror of
what happened at parkland the media's
first move was to jump to the suggestion
that everyone who disagreed with them on
gun control was of course in asking me
now this is nothing new and I sort of
got famous off of saying exactly this to
Piers Morgan because Piers Morgan was
famous for doing this I said to him that
he was standing on the graves of the
kids at Sandy Hook to push his agenda
and the media continued to do this
tonight of course CNN is supposed to
have a big town hall event where they
have a bunch of the students from
Parkland we'll see if they have any of
the students from power plants who are
not in favor of gun control the answer
is probably not but the media have been
using these students in order to push
their gun control agenda now I have
never attempted to smear the students
themselves I've never said that the
students don't have a right to speak I
have never insulted the students pain
I've never insulted what the students
went through but because I say that you
ought to have expertise on the topic if
we're going to take you seriously this
is enough to get you labeled a smear of
the students so Huffington Post led the
way last night they put up a headline
that looked like this and it's just
egregious it says survivors mirrors with
a picture of me personally and says some
conservatives are trying to discredit
outspoken Florida shooting survivors I
have not tried to discredit any shooting
survivor
I have not smeared at any any shooting
survivor that's absurd it's insulting
and it's disgusting the only thing that
I have said about the shooting survivors
is the same thing that I said about
Jimmy Kimmel when it came to him
bringing his son on the show after his
son went through an open-heart surgery
which is just because you went through
suffering does not make you an expert on
a particular topic this has been my
consistent stance on virtually every
event of major consequence in the United
States for my entire career is that just
because he went through something
doesn't mean that you have been
conferred with certain expertise and
that's what I wrote over at National
Review I had a long piece on it I
discussed it on the show but the idea
that that is disrespect to the students
to suggest that perhaps they don't know
all the details what they're talking
about or at the very least they have to
show expertise in the topic for me to
take their opinions more seriously I'm
happy to take their opinions on what
pain and suffering of people who've gone
through a difficult situation looks like
yeah they are experts and having gone
through a traumatic situation so I'm
happy to hear their advice on what it's
like to go through a traumatic situation
in fact I think that's deeply important
stuff for people to hear but I'm not
willing to to sacrifice the the point
public policy on the basis of I went
through something bad because that makes
for bad public policy good public policy
is not based on empathy good public
policy is based on reason and logic but
that of course is enough to get you
labeled a smear of the survivors
according to the mainstream media and
they've been doing this for days I mean
for days and days and days they've been
doing this promoting lies about gun
control promoting lies about people who
oppose gun control and for example Van
Jones
who I personally know and I like van
he's an opinion host but he retweeted
may a tweet from a woman named Laurie
shoot who tweeted common denominators
for mass shooters white males under 30 a
ar-15s Republicans so first of all maybe
ar-15s maybe not that a bunch of other
weapons that have been used in these
mass shootings but there is no indicator
that these mass shooters were
Republicans even if you want to say that
the powerclean shooter was a Republican
because there's a picture of him more
than a maganet
well earlier this year or late last year
we had a shooting in a congressional
baseball game from Bernie Sanders
supporter that didn't mean that Bernie
Sanders was responsible for the shooting
of the Congressional baseball players
that's absurd
but Van Jones retweeted that anyway and
that's not the only example of the media
covering themselves in glory Chris Cuomo
earlier this morning made a fool of
himself by tweeting something out that
was patently false that Chris Cuomo
tweeted out a story from an account
called Cody Davis I guess us a photo
dude and the tweet said quote I was able
to buy an ar-15 in five minutes I'm 20
and my ID is expired well there's only
one problem that never happened
according to the article at self quote
after the sales representative walked me
through the paperwork all five pages of
it I told him I changed my mind and
wanted to think more before I bought an
ar-15 he told me it wasn't a problem and
listed the store hours if I wanted to
come back and then said thank you and
walked back to my car so in other words
he didn't present an ID and no gun was
offered to him he said that he wasn't
going to present an ID he left this
stored that was the end of the story it
didn't matter Chris Cuomo tweeted out
Eli that he was offered an ar-15 without
photo ID now when he was called on this
Chris Cuomo over at Siena and the the
the block of wood who who attempts to
resemble him and being over at CNN Chris
Cuomo actually tweeted out isn't the
point that the kids age and lack of ID
wasn't the deterrent and this isn't all
gun shops place I bought my shotgun
basically goes farther than law requires
and makes judgments about whom to sell
to point is the system should be better
well
why and the system worked here he didn't
try to eat and get a gun I'm wondering
that they ran a federal background check
if you go to a federally licensed
firearms dealer in the United States
according to federal law they must run a
federal background check for a criminal
record as well as mental health record
by the way the problem is that these
records are not fully transparent
sometimes the information is not
conveyed down to the federal government
to the FBI so charles cook over at
national review called cuomo on this he
said the point is that the kid lied
about buying a gun that you didn't and
now you're lying - so Cuomo immediately
misdirected - an unrelated topic he said
lying if you want to fight back against
background checks make the case whether
it is calling the kids actors are lying
about how no laws could stop the
shootings that is the BS to call out 97%
of people want better checks why fight
that well it's a complete misdirect that
has nothing to do with the fact that
Chris Cuomo and respected objective news
source tweeted out something that is
objectively false it is just not true
now in a second I'm going to talk about
the stupidity of people on the right who
are pushing myths about the about like
people who actually are smearing this
school the school shooting survivors by
suggesting that one of them particularly
a guy named David Hogg is 17 years old
is some sort of crisis actor they're
putting out this video that shows that
he was interviewed by a local CBS News
in Los Angeles a few months back over
some incident where he was a witness and
they're saying well this shows that he
was a child actor because he was out in
Los Angeles and so he's acting well he
was at the shooting whether he is a
child actor or not makes no difference I
have no evidence that he is what the
hell are you talking about is the
suggestion that he's being paid for his
perspective I mean my understanding is
that from his Twitter account he was
anti-gun before this happened is the
idea that he's being paid as an actor to
pretend that he saw a shooting he did
not because there's no evidence of that
either and that's a smear and that's a
lie
that's the number one trending video on
YouTube by the way and it's disgusting
anybody who's trafficking and
trafficking and that should immediately
be discounted as a decent news source
that's stupidity there dinesh d'souza
got himself in hot water yesterday
because Dinesh tweeted something out
about how the they're a bunch of kids
were crying when a piece of gun
legislation didn't pass in the Florida
Legislature and Dinesh tweeted something
out about how this is the worst these
kids have suffered since their parents
told them that they were scaling back
their allowance or they couldn't get a
summer job that of course is ridiculous
there was literally a shooting in
Florida last week
Dinesh got shot
for that as well he should have and
hands it up backing down and apologizing
for it but there's been inordinately dia
focus placed on that YouTube video
particularly and on the comments of
folks like Dinesh hey every member of
the mainstream media that's all deserve
by the way I mean there should be focus
on lies but the lies extend to the
mainstream media itself and it's much
more prominent in the mainstream media
because virtually every major host in
the mainstream media are engaging is
engaging in this type of lie virtually
all of them or at least in selective
coverage that is designed to shade your
emotions in a particular direction so as
an example of this last night Anderson
Cooper was was talking about gun
violence about shootings involving guns
and here's what he had to say I actually
think we don't focus on the reality of
what an ar-15 does to a child I mean if
anyone has been on a battlefield and
you've seen what a weapon like this does
to a soldier I mean I think if people
actually saw this and saw the reality of
this I mean it's it would open people's
eyes I mean we were talking about we're
not talking about you know we all say
all these children lost their lives they
didn't lose their lives their lives were
ripped out of their bodies their brains
were splattered on the floor their
intestines are hanging out I mean it's
sickening and like we're all talking
about it in this antiseptic way and
we're shocked that these kids are angry
when they've been hiding in closets and
their friends are dead okay that's all
fine I mean if he wants to discuss this
in in graphic terms that's fine I'm not
sure that the graphicness of the act
actually changes the the logic behind
gun control because the whole point here
is not a lack of sympathy see what
Cooper's trying to do a lot of folks in
the media are trying to do is they're
trying to say look how horrible things
are therefore if you don't agree with me
on policy it's because you don't think
these things are horrible that's
backwards logic and there's no real that
there's no reason to it I'm gonna
explain more about that and also I have
an additional note for Anderson Cooper
in just a second first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at Dollar
Shave Club so Dollar Shave Club is the
place to go if you want the best shave
you want that clean nice shave and you
want it in in less expensive fashion
than having to go to the the local Rite
Aid or CVS well the best way to do that
is with the Dollar Shave Club and they
have everything I mean everything you
need to look smelt feel you're about
shampoo body wash toothpaste and of
course the best rate
that you can use you get that amazing
high-quality shave every morning from
the Dollar Shave Club executive razor
they are the gold standard
so right now join Dollar Shave Club and
for five bucks with Free Shipping you'll
get their starter set so what's in the
starter set well the six blade executive
razor and it is magnificent plus trial
sizes of the shave butter the body
cleanser and of course the fabled famous
one wipe Charlies oh yes indeed the butt
wipes then you keep the blades coming
for a few bucks more per month you get
yours at dollarshaveclub.com slash bend
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash bends
you get that trial with at 5.45 bucks
you get the trial sizes of all these
things he can see if you like them and
once you subscribe you're gonna be
getting the new razors in the mail all
the time it is great and it means that
you're never gonna have to worry about
what soap to get again you're never
gonna have to worry about what shaving
cream you get again you're never gonna
have to worry about replacing your
razors ever again Dollar Shave Club is
the best there's a reason they're one of
the best companies in America when it
comes to this stuff dollarshaveclub.com
slash been check them out that also lets
them know that we sent you and use the
slash been and get the special deal the
five dollars and you get the you get the
travel kit including of course those one
wipe Charlies which are just
astonishingly great so just check that
out dollarshaveclub.com slash then all
right so Mac to Anderson Cooper so you
heard Anderson Cooper there talk about
the the brutality and the violence and
the horrible imagery of kids being shot
yes and all Americans agree that's
terrible I will point out the selective
coverage of the media when it comes to
antiseptic coverage of killings so I did
one one of the videos that I've done
that's been seen the most is a video of
me from this show talking in specific
terms about what actually happens during
an abortion the dismemberment of bodies
in the womb in in late-stage abortion
the the cracking open of the skull of
babies and sucking their brains into
sinks no one in the mainstream media
will ever talk about that ever not in 1
million years the room that Anderson
Cooper will never do a 30 second a 30
second description of what an abortion
actually is like instead he will just
use antiseptic terms to describe it the
points your being that if the media want
to get graphic about how they cover
crime if the mean you want to get
graphic about how they cover killings
and violence then that's fine with me
get graphic about how you cover crimes
and killings and violence that's I have
no problem with that as a general rule I
think that in fact that's sometimes
useful if people really are unable to
connect what a crime is with the
sure of the crime itself but you can't
be selective about it you can't just say
that you're gonna do it with regards to
shooting victims but not with stabbing
victims they're gonna do it with regard
to shooting victims but not bombing
victims we didn't hear a graphic
descriptions of what happened to people
on 9/11 right the news media and this
actual critical of this the news media
stopped showing that the the video of
people who are hurling themselves from
the top stories of buildings because
they didn't want to lead people to to
feel angry or feel bad and I said I
don't like the media censoring that so I
don't really have a problem with
Anderson Cooper talking about the
effective guns this is what it's true
this is what a bullet fired at Hyde the
high velocity does right it malls the
human body it destroys the human body
it destroys anything that it's shot at
this is why the first rule literally the
first rule of gun in training is do not
point the gun at anything that you're
not willing to destroy that is literally
rule number one when it comes to guns if
you pick up a gun then don't point it
anywhere where it is possible that you
will destroy something that you care
about and that includes human beings
this is what the NRA teaches in every
one of its gun safety courses but the
point is that the media are only doing
this with regard to shootings now
because they're pushing a particular
political agenda and the problem here is
that if you want to be an opinion host
in to this that's fine if you want to
say that you're an objective news host
in to it that's a completely different
story Brooke Baldwin doing the same
routine over on CNN she was lecturing
the Trump administration suggesting that
the Trump administration was hiding
somehow from from the media on all of
this stuff even though that was not the
case they had a press conference
yesterday but here's Brooke Baldwin when
the press conference is delayed by about
15 minutes saying that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders in the White House were hiding
from the media on gun control memo to
the White House you cannot avoid us stop
trying to dodge us this briefing needs
to begin it was supposed to begin an
hour and 15 minutes ago and then it was
supposed to begin 25 minutes ago there
was a lot to talk about
and we need to see Sarah Sanders behind
that podium Jeff's elleny and Gloria
Borger are with me and I think it is
entirely fair Jeff Zeleny to be tough on
this White House because there are so
many things they need to answer for
before the ceremony at the half hour
okay does that sound like objective news
coverage here or does it sound like we
want you out there so we can grill you
on our preferred agenda with regard to
guns and that's of course with the media
continue to do so one reporter was
grilling Sarah Huckabee Sanders
yesterday suggesting that the
president wasn't doing anything now as
we will talk about the president
actually is looking at doing some stuff
with regard to guns it may not be all
the things the left wants him to do
because maybe he doesn't think those
things are going to be particularly
effective in stopping mass shootings one
of the big problems with a lot of the
gun control proposals that are being put
on the table is that there is no clear
link between the gun control proposal
put on the table and the actual
lessening of mass shootings the only gun
control proposal that the left is really
put on the table to to lessen mass
shootings is confiscation of all guns
which is completely unrealistic it's
never going to happen and then if you
say it's unrealistic and it's never
gonna happen they accuse you of smearing
shooting survivors or some such nonsense
or not caring about the kids who died
which again is total crap but here is
what it looks like when the media grills
the Obama administration on gun control
working hand-in-hand with both the
federal government as well as state and
local law officials law enforcement
officials on what we legally can do
unfortunately we can't just flip a
switch but there is a process there we
are a law-and-order country and the
president is trying to do everything
that he can under his capacity to
address these concerns and certainly
when it comes to mental illness but the
minute the media wouldn't have any of
that they were just they were just
grilling sarah huckabee senators how
dare you not have a one-size-fits-all
solution to to mass shootings and the
answer is nobody does right even Obama
said that when he was in office and he
was pushing particularly gun control
proposals like banning ar-15s for
example he would say in his speeches
this may not stop on mass shooting this
may not stop any mass shootings he would
say that sort of stuff and the media
would just ignore that which leads a lot
of donors to believe hey well if that
it's not what you're doing then what
exactly are you doing here now look the
media obviously have an agenda here they
have it and how they cover these stories
they have it in the people they choose
to interview there's a Katy tur over at
MSNBC interviewed a guy who said that he
was gonna become a school shooter but he
didn't become a school shooter because
he didn't have access to guns here's
what that interview looked like some
people blame this violence on the media
or video games or music we call those
people morons but there is one thing
that would have made it all different I
didn't have access to an assault rifle I
was almost a school shooter I am NOT a
school shooter because I didn't have
access to guns guns don't kill people
people kill people but people with
guns kill lots of people you know that
and then there's the guy who says that
he was a would-be mass shooter well how
do we know what would have stopped him
and what would not have stopped him or
if he'd like is it legal in the state of
Colorado he's from Colorado for him to
walk into a gun store at the age of 15
by rifle I don't know the gun laws in
the state of Colorado I somehow doubt it
but it doesn't matter this is the agenda
and the agenda must be pushed at all
costs regardless of the underlying facts
it's it's just this is not how the media
should be doing their jobs and they're
not doing their jobs what they're doing
is the job of the left and then they
wonder it's so funny they sit around
going Trump Trump attacks us and that's
why our credibility is shot with the
American people their credibility was
shot long before Trump in 2012 Newt
Gingrich made a lot of hay he won a
couple of primaries based on him in the
in the debate criticizing the media I
said at the time that if anyone wanted
to win primaries they should criticize
the media I've been saying that for
years
Trump was the only one who did it on a
regular basis and he tapped into
something that was a pre-existing
wellspring of distrust of the media that
exists specifically because it is
obvious that they are pushing a
political agenda CNN doing this routine
scene that's been the worst of all the
network's on this I mean it's just been
garbage on this CNN is now pushing an
agenda saying that 16 year old should
vote here's here's what they tweet it
out and then they suggested that it says
should 16 year olds be able to vote the
response it's Stoneman Douglas High is
showing that youth in this country can
and should have a significant role in
political debate rights law professor
Joshua Douglas via CNN opinion really is
that what it shows because what it seems
to me is what it shows that you are
willing to use as the media the most
sympathetic person that you can find in
order to promulgate your agenda that's
that's what it is saying to me because
here's what the data say to me the data
say to me that 18 to 29 year olds are
more pro-gun than people who are older
so it's funny then the media will never
report these polls 2015 Pew survey these
put up by Lachlan Marquis over at Daily
Beast found 18 to 29 year olds are less
likely than older Americans to support a
ban on assault weapons just 49 percent
of Millennials were for the assault
weapons ban compared the 55 percent of
30 to 49 year old 61 percent to 50 to 64
year olds and 63 percent of those 65 and
older meanwhile 18 to 29 year olds lead
the country in support for concealed
carry according to a 2015 Gallup poll
they're more likely to support the
practice of carrying a hidden firearm in
public by a full 10
at 66% so the idea that all these kids
are sitting around looking to seize the
guns no it's just that you wanna you
want to feature certain children it's
not that you care that 16 year olds but
you don't want 16 year olds to vote now
you want 16 year olds to be treated as
children when they commit crimes but
adults when it comes to voting it
doesn't work that way either kids or
kids or kids or adults it can't have it
both ways but obviously the media's
agenda here
uber alles that's all that that's all
that matters in the end is how the media
decides to cover all of this stuff and
that's just it's just gross it's just
gross because not about providing the
American public with information it's
about providing them with a fully
created narrative that is going to be
used to club all rivals into submission
okay
meanwhile the the Trump is actually
doing stuff so Trump yesterday said that
who's gonna move to ban bub stocks that
doesn't make a lot of sense in response
to the parklands shooting but it does
make some sense in response to Las Vegas
shooting I suggested it at the time bump
stocks are a an addendum that you can
put on the back on the butt of a rifle
that essentially allows the the rifle to
move back and forth against your
shoulder very quickly and if you hold
your finger steady
then the trigger hits your finger all
right so the trigger it goes like that
over and over and over very very quickly
using the momentum from the from the
kickback of the gun to to power that
sort of bouncing action so the shooter
in Las Vegas used a bump stock there was
no bomb stock ban on the books Trump
says yesterday that he's going to move
to drop regulations to ban bump stocks
Attorney General to clarify whether
certain bump stock devices like the one
used in Las Vegas are illegal under
current law that process began in
December and just a few moments ago I
signed a memorandum directing the
Attorney General to propose regulations
to ban all devices that turn legal
weapon okay so it is not clear by the
way that attack is actually legal for
the DOJ to use existing law and order
ban bump stocks you might need a
separate piece of legislation because
the gun itself is not a machine gun this
is an addendum to a a semi-automatic
weapon it's a piece that you add to a
semi-automatic weapon for those in the
media who don't understand the
difference between
my auto and in Auto a semi auto means
that when every trigger pole is one
round that is chambered and fired and in
an automatic weapon means that the law
as long as you're holding down the
trigger multiple bullets are being fired
so that's the difference between the two
the white house also said that they
would look into the possibility of
raising the age limit for purchase of
ar-15 type rifles again there's certain
inconsistency here if you're gonna raise
the age limit for buying a rifle then
you should also raise the age limit for
presumably joining the military maybe or
or voting the bottom line is our 18 year
olds adults are they're not adults right
now we have very inconsistent view of
when people become adults you're 18 for
purposes of voting but you're 21 for
purposes of drinking and I'm not sure
how that works exactly so you can you
can be in the military and at 18 years
old but you can't actually have a beer
until you're 21 that's a sort of weird
thing or you can be in the military at
18 but you can't leave the military and
then go purchase a rifle even though you
were just in the military there's a
little bit of incoherence there I'm not
completely opposed to the idea of
raising the age limit on this stuff but
I'm not sure that it's going to have a
tremendous effect given though the laws
around the nation already with regard to
to buying ar-15s there was a lot of
hubbub yesterday after Florida voted
down in the salt weapons ban as well
we'll talk about that in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at filter by so in Dallas
it's 11 degrees New York's been nine
degrees Minneapolis minus two degrees
it's really really really cold outside
LA is really cold right now for no
reason at all and that means everybody's
indoors and that means that you're using
your heating system in all likelihood
well instead of you sitting there
breathing in dirty air because you
haven't replaced your filters in a while
now you need to go to filter by comm it
is America's leading provider of HVAC
filters for homes and small businesses
filter by comm carries over 600
different filter sizes including custom
options all ship free within 24 hours
plus they are manufactured right here in
America filter by offers a multitude of
em ERV options all the way up to
hospital grades you'll be removing a
dangerous pollen mold dust other allergy
aggravating pollution while maximizing
the efficiency of your system right now
you can save five percent when you set
up auto delivery so you never need to
think about air filters again again
that's filter by comm filter bu why.com
go there make sure that the air that
your kids are breathing is the safe
and cleanest air possible even me
spending a lot of time indoors and
usually the air indoors is dirtier than
the air outdoors so make sure that's not
the case at your house filter by calm
again filter by calm and right now you
say five percent when you setup auto
delivery so you'll never need to think
about it again after you go to over to
filter by comm and register okay so
other things that are that are on the
table Florida just voted down and I
full-on quote unquote
assault weapons ban it wasn't an assault
weapons ban that's that's bad media
coverage again instead it was actually a
ban on air 15s ar-15s are not assault
weapons yeah assault weapons are a
legally dubious definition there's no
clear definition of what constitutes an
assault weapon an ar-15 is just a high
grade rifle that's all it is but if you
add a few gadgets to it it becomes an
assault weapon if you have like a pistol
grip to it to a rifle then in in some
cases that becomes an assault weapon if
you add a sight to it sometimes it
becomes an assault weapon if it's
painted black as opposed to being brown
sometimes that's an assault weapon in
any case this made a lot of media a lot
of garnered a lot of media attention
because that bunch of the students from
Marjory Stoneman Douglas high school
went to Florida lawmakers in Tallahassee
and asked for a full ban on the outter
15 the final motion vote was 36 to 70
once was overwhelmingly voted down the
Democratic Representative Keyon McGee
asked for a procedural move that would
have allowed it to consider the ban and
the bill to ban quote assault rifles in
large capacity magazines the bill had
been assigned to three committees but
was not scheduled for a hearing so the
house will determine whether they choose
to do that or not obviously the media
ran with the photos of the Weeping
students because they want to generate
sympathy for the anti-gun agenda and
this doesn't mean the student should be
mocked as Dinesh did yesterday obviously
I understand that kids have really
strong feelings about everyone has very
strong feelings about these issues and
these kids just went through a trauma
that's why I'm not in favor of what I
think his media exploitation of people
who just went through a tragedy in order
to gin up sympathy for a particular
agenda I think that the media only does
this again with particular circumstances
they didn't do it after the Boston
bombing they didn't have big town halls
with victims of the Boston bombing
talking about immigration policy for
example but they do do this every time
there is a gun and in an issue of gun
violence that crops up by the way
worthwhile noting here that some of the
statistics that have been going around
regard to mass shootings in the United
States are just that wrong as I've
explained before it is just not true it
is it is a falsity that there were 18
mass shootings in the United States in
January it's not true it was more like
two that's horrible but it's not 18 also
it's been promoted by the media that the
United States the only advanced country
in which mass violence occurs that mass
shootings occur that is not true if you
actually look per capita if you look per
capita mass shootings the United States
actually comes in eleventh so the way
that you calculate that this is the
crime prevention Research Center headed
by economist John Lott who's famously
the author of more guns less crime which
has been true in the United States for a
while the gun the gun murder rate has
been declining rapidly in the United
States for the last 20 years even though
the number of guns in circulation in the
United States has been rising rapidly
for the last 20 years John Lott says
that the u.s. does not lead the world in
mass shootings in fact it doesn't even
make the top ten when you measure death
rate per million population from mass
public shootings now to be fair there's
a fair margin of error here because mass
shootings everywhere are pretty rare
when you have a country of 330 million
people and let's say a hundred people a
year are killed in mass shootings which
is very high that's not high that number
is a lot higher than it actually is in
the United States well that that recedes
into margin of error territory but if
you look at 2009 through 2015 if you
look at the top death rate per million
people from mass public shootings goes
Norway Serbia France Macedonia Albania
Slovakia Switzerland Finland Belgium
Czech Republic and then the United
States also as far as frequency that is
also not true
the u.s. ranks 12th compared to European
countries in terms of frequency per
capita now per capita matter is because
the United States is a very large
country with a lot of people and so
you're going to have to measure the rate
of violence in the United States as
opposed to rates of violence per capita
in other European countries so don't buy
into the the notion that the United
States is replete with mass shootings
there happening every day on every
corner does that mean that there's
nothing we can do to stop it no of
course it doesn't mean that I've
suggested on this program multiple
things we can do ranging from better
security in school situations to the gun
violence restraining orders promoted by
David French over at National Review in
which family members can apply to the
court to have your capacity to buy a gun
or own a gun temporarily removed from
you if you're a danger to yourself or
others but that's not enough the left
just wants to shout about
how everybody who doesn't agree with
them is a bad person and they're not
going to stop until that happens this is
this is a fool's errand for the White
House for the White House is is gonna
hold a listening session with students
according to Sara Huckabee Sanders this
is because the media been putting a lot
of pressure on the White House saying
you're not listening to the victims
again I don't remember anybody doing
this with Barack Obama and for example
the victims in Benghazi I don't remember
them doing this with the victims of the
Boston bombing I don't remember the I
don't remember of the family of the the
beheaded by Isis doing this with Barack
Obama but I guess we have to do this
with with President Trump Sarah Huckabee
Sanders says Trump is actually gonna get
in a room with a lot of these students
and presumably take it from them Trump
is actually good at this it'll be good
for Trump politically you know the
aftermath probably won't be heavy gun
legislation but it's smart of him
politically to get in a room with these
kids because Trump contrary to popular
opinion does have a capacity for
sympathy when he is listening to people
one-on-one is virtually everyone who's
dealt with him one-on-one will tell you
here's Sarah Huckabee Sanders announcing
this tomorrow will be hosting parents
teachers and students here at the White
House to discuss efforts to ensure
safety at our schools members of the
Parkland community will be attending
this listening session as will
individuals who were impacted by past
school shootings including the Columbine
and Sandy Hook tragedies on Thursday we
will be hosting local officials
including members of the law enforcement
community to continue that conversation
as the president has said many times it
is the right of every American child to
grow up in a safe community that begins
in America's neighborhoods okay so this
is I think a smart move by the Trump
administration to demonstrate that
there's no lack of sympathy even if
there is a lack of agreement on public
policy some of the agreement on public
policy the lack of agreement is coming
from the fact that folks on the Left
refused to even consider possibilities
that they haven't thought about right so
Doug Jones the the senator from Alabama
he was asked about the possibility of
arming teachers and I've said that I
think the teachers who are trained and
qualified should be able to carry
firearms Doug Jones says all that's
idiotic we shouldn't arm teachers I'm
not even consider it forming teachers in
schools and that's an idea that
representative Bradley Bern and Senator
Doug Jones had
when opinions about there are some
teachers that I think could be
appropriately armed if they have the
training they feel comfortable doing it
I would certainly wouldn't want to
require them to do it if they don't feel
comfortable with it I think that's a
dumbest idea I've ever heard I think
it's crazy
you don't need to arm America in order
to stop this well actually you do need
to arm Americans in order to stop mass
shooters because it's always the police
who stopped mass shooters but again this
is this debate is so dishonest and it's
so yucky and really it turns your guts
because there are so many people who are
well who are not willing to lend the
other side the credibility of hearing
out the their their proposals or willing
to acknowledge the people on the other
side of the issue may in fact care about
children being killed okay so speaking
of media bias let's talk a little bit
about a new poll that's out with regard
to the GOP tax cut so there's an brand
new poll that's out and it shows that
the GOP tax cut is up to 51% support
overall from 37% in December 89% among
Republicans and 19% among Democrats okay
that is a massive growth in the in the
level of support for the tax cuts in one
of the reasons is because people are
finally starting to see the tax cuts hit
their paycheck they got their February
paycheck and the tax cuts were present
in the paycheck and so suddenly it's
more popular it also goes to show you
the level of media lies and malfeasance
on the tax cut and you can see that at a
time I talked about this while they were
passing the tax cut you could actually
see in the polls the vast majority of
the American public thought they would
not receive a tax cut still only thirty
five percent of the American public
believes that they're going to receive a
tax cut it's closer to eighty to ninety
percent of the American public and then
the media wonder why we don't trust them
why we think that they're biased on
these issues they are biased on these
issues and I'll show you how bias they
are also on the Trump brushes stuff in
just a second but first you're gonna
have to go over to Daily wire calm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire comm when
you do you get the rest of our show live
to get the rest of the Andrew Klavan
show live the rest of the Michael Mol's
show live thank you by the way to all
those folks who are over subscribing and
Andrew Clavin show he was up to the top
ten I believe we're close to the top ten
on iTunes
overnight which is just fantastic his
shows definitely worth the listen and
work the subscribership but also
subscribe at daily wire.com for $9.99
monthly and get his entire show alive be
part of his mailbag if you want all of
that plus the world-famous leftist
year's hot or cold tumbler check that
out over at daily we're calm the annual
subscription gets you 99
it's 99 bucks a year instead of $9.99 a
month you saved 20 bucks off the regular
subscription price and you get that
fabulous beverage vessel you just want
to listen later go over to iTunes
SoundCloud google play stitcher any of
the places you got your podcast you can
get the Ben Shapiro show subscribe leave
us a review we always appreciate it we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
speaking of Trump Russia collusion
there's another robert mueller
investigation indictment somebody has
pled guilty again it has nothing to do
with actual collusion between the Trump
administration and Russia and the last
few weeks have not been good for people
who have been pushing the lie that the
Trump administration was clearly
colluding with referent out maybe there
will be no evidence that emerges maybe
we will find out later that the Trump
administration was working hand in glove
with Vladimir Putin to swivel the
election in Wisconsin maybe that's what
we'll find out but I haven't seen the
evidence of that you haven't seen the
evidence of that because nobody's seen
the evidence that but that is not
actually stopping members of the
Democratic Party in the media from
pushing that lie anyway Hakeem Jeffries
the Democratic Representative he came
out yesterday said that Trump did
collude to steal the election but we
also have to stay focused here on what
the problem is it seems that the Trump
campaign conspired with Russian spies to
sell out our democracy and now you have
members closely affiliated with the
Trump administration and possibly the
president who are engaged in a cover-up
that's a problem and we should just
allow the Muller investigation to run
its course okay I'm in favor of allowing
another investigation run its course but
it seems like you're jumping to
conclusions there I came I mean yeah you
you are you're you're suggesting
something that is just not an evidence
you're assuming facts not in evidence
so yesterday President Trump tweeted out
that he was that he had been much
tougher on Russia than President Obama
had been fact-check true
the media ran with the most bizarre
headline so look at this from CNN this
is a clip 17 look at this
from CNN you'll see a headline that they
put up okay the one on the Left says
Trump has been tougher on Russia in in
then then Obama was in eighth they he's
been tougher on Russia in in the first
in one year than Obama wasn't eight and
then it says in parentheses right there
fact-checking in the chyron in the
parentheses says no he hasn't
and Natasha Bertrand who covers the
media says Ciena not pulling any punches
tonight um that's not only them not
pulling punches that's them lying trump
has been tougher on Russia in one year
than the Obama administration wasn't it
I love this idea that suddenly the Obama
administration was tough on Russia in
2012 President Obama running for
reelection said directly to Dmitry
Medvedev that he should commit that he
should tell Vladimir Putin that there
would be more flexibility after the
election if the Russians backed off he
said that on and
and Mike he said that Mitt Romney who is
calling Russia the number one
geopolitical threat the 1980s called him
want their foreign policy back then he
handed over leadership of the Syrian
situation to the Russians and the
Russians have continued to prop up a
regime that is engaging in massive human
rights violation
certain human rights violations so
massive that the UN literally put out a
resolution I think two days ago saying
that we have no more words condemned
what's happening in Syria that's what
the resolution actually said and yet
we're now being told that Obama was
tougher on Russia then Trump was Obama
wasn't even in tough on Russia
interfering in the election right Obama
the Trump has a point here he does have
a point when he says that you know if
Russia was interfering the election so
much where was Obama well they were
interfering in the election and where
was Obama and the answer is that Obama
didn't want to piss off the Russians
because he thinks that the Russians were
a valuable strategic Ally on the Iran
deal that's the reality of why he didn't
want to tick off the Russians he thinks
that the Russians should have a
leadership role in the Middle East so
CNN is lying about that too when they
said oh but that Obama was tougher on
Russia than Trump is it's just a joke
it's not true Jonah Goldberg
okay another person who is not Pro Trump
right I am NOT by any stretch of the
imagination if you've ever listened to
the show a president Trump Lackey
neither as Jonah Goldberg at National
Review I don't think either one of us
voted for President Trump in fact I know
neither one of us did here is what he
writes he says there's one unfortunate
thing with the Trump tweet Trump has a
point
Barack Obama sold out our Eastern
European allies on missile defense he
slowed off 280 Ukraine as opposed to
Trump who's actually provided material
aid Ukraine he did a little more than
shrug when Crimea was annexed he said
never mind on his own red line in Syria
and turned a blind eye to Putin's
intervention there in large part because
of his obsessions of getting the Iran
deal the Russian meddling in our
elections started on Obama's watch and
not just our elections but those of many
of our allies when Romney famously said
Russia was our number one geopolitical
foe Obama mocked him for it as did
countless liberal journalists were now
converts to anti-russia horary meanwhile
the Trump administration has made life
harder for Russia diplomatically and
economically thanks to revving up our
oil and gas production it hasn't been as
tough as some including me would like
but it's been tougher than the Obama
administration or at least it's not
unreasonable so the the reason that that
the media are mocking Trump on this
stuff is because Trump has said so many
nice things about Putin and because he
seems to lend a lot of credibility to
Putin this is another case there's so
many cases in the Trump administration
where a good policy is at odds with bad
rhetoric where
policy is actually pretty good decent in
some cases great and then he goes out
and says something dumb and he
undermines the policy but the media are
lying when they say to you that Obama
was tough on Russia and Trump is not
tough on Russia it's just not true it is
not factually accurate doesn't matter
media will live out it anyway Jim
sciutto
over at over at CNN says it's delusional
to say the Trump has been facing down
Russia listen you know you can argue and
it's a fair criticism to say did the
Obama administration act quickly or
strong enough strongly enough with
Russia and that's a criticism you've
heard from both Democrats and
Republicans but when you compare the
Trump administration response basically
this president's response and the Obama
administration's response Mr Sanders is
entering really delusional territory
there come no it's not okay so if you
want to say that the the Trump
administration response to Russian
election meddling has been lackluster at
best I agree if you want to say the
Trump administration response to Russia
generally has been weaker than the Obama
administration that is just not true and
it's foolish and again you wonder why
people don't trust the media because you
keep lying because people in the media
keep lying I think the truth on all
sides would be a good thing I have
criticized President Trump when I think
that he is not telling the truth and I
have criticized the media land I think
they are not telling the truth right now
the media are doing themselves no favors
especially because they shouldn't be in
the business of pushing an agenda
Trump's agenda isn't to tell truth
Trump's agenda is to push Trump's agenda
and from Sargento very often is to push
Trump well that means sometimes is gonna
be dishonest just like other politicians
are dishonest in some cases more so but
CNN's agenda was supposed to be
objective truth which they are not
providing on any level at this point
their coverage in the last couple of
weeks has been really disheartening
these are the people who say an apple is
an apple not a banana well then stop
creating apple banana smoothies and
calling them apples because it's just
ridiculous it's just ridiculous no have
you ever miss if I didn't take a minute
to note the death of the world's
best-known evangelist Reverend Billy
Graham he died on Wednesday he was 99
years old and he was responsible for an
enormous amount he was using who's
responsible for an enormous number of
conversions an enormous number of
celebrities came to came to Christianity
through Billy Graham and Billy Graham it
was not the media tried to portray him
in many cases this sort of this sort of
odd this odd Elmer Gantry character
that's not who Billy Graham was
miligrams lectures it was it was deeply
not only religious stuff but stuff about
self-sacrifice and stuff about
responsibility Billy Graham had a great
impact on the world this is why when
people talk about how religion has had a
nasty impact on the world look at the
followers of Billy Graham and ask how
many followers of Billy Graham have made
their lives better because of the
thought because they followed Billy
Graham there's in the aftermath of
tragedy there's an easy swing toward
atheism agnosticism the idea that you'd
be better off if you didn't believe in
God better people don't believe in God
that somehow the world would be better
if a theism were to rule the roost we've
heard this from thinkers I respect
including Sam Harris and Steven Pinker
in the last couple of days and this is
not true for the vast majority of
individuals around planet Earth people
who become atheistic are less likely to
engage in communal activities people who
become an atheistic are less likely to
give to charity people who become
atheistic are less likely to to engage
in the sort of social fabric building
that's necessary in order for a thriving
society to survive and that's not even a
case for the veracity of Christianity or
Judaism that I'm making this is a case
for the social utility of Christianity
or Judaism all the folks who are living
in a free and open and and good country
can thank people like Billy Graham for
turning the lives around of people many
people who would otherwise have have led
terrible lives I mean they're there a
lot of people who were who were
hell-bent on leading bad lives and Billy
Graham was instrumental in preventing
that from happening as are so many other
religious leaders now that doesn't mean
that religion is always a force for good
of course not it doesn't mean that
religion always makes people better that
would be silly it does mean that
religion when used properly can be a
solution to a lot of people's life
problems and it can be an encouragement
to do better because there is someone
who expects something more of you and
it's not just your friends or family
it's not even just you it's a higher
power that expects you to make something
of your life and discover a purpose I
think the death of God in American
society has been a contributing factor
to the sort of political fractious nough
seen here we used to at least hold it in
common not only that we were all made in
God's image but that if we all help
common values in common
we knew our neighbors cared about the
dead kids in Sandy Hook or cared about
the the murdered children in parkland
right we took that for granted because
these were the same people that we saw
at church every week these are the same
people who are giving to the same
charities that we were but because we've
lost that communal space it's a lot
easier to
in your house and go on Twitter or
Facebook and malign people who you've
never met because you've never met your
neighbors how many of us have actually
met our neighbors now in California it's
become really uncommon I know that
there's still places in the country
where you know your neighbors
particularly in small town America I
grew up in Los Angeles knowing your
neighbors was not a prereq one of the
things that you see when you drive
through different areas of the country
it's really fascinating is which areas
have fences between yards and which
don't so if you go over to Dallas for
example big city but if you drive around
suburban Dallas there are no fences
between the actual yards and all the
yards are basically connected there may
be some driveways but they're not big
fences if you drive through the valley
and which is which is where I've lived
most of my life you drive through the
San Fernando Valley well you'll see is
that most of the yards are not connected
most of the yards are separated by walls
most of the yards are separated by
fences they're fenced off there's
nothing wrong with the wall there's
nothing wrong with the fence but it is
indicative of the fact that community is
less common in big cities than it is in
small towns and it's less it's less
common in urban areas than it is in
rural areas and it's less common in
non-religious areas than it is in
religious areas this is why you've seen
in the last few years the rise in
atheist get-togethers they've been
trying to create almost an atheistic
religious get-together where you have
community events and all the rest of us
and it hasn't been working because why
should a theist get together to talk
about why God doesn't exist that seems
like a rather uninspiring vision of the
world why would you get together with
people who also don't believe God exists
that frees you to find any purpose in
life supposedly but you're gonna end up
with a lot of different purposes and a
lot of those purposes are going to be
working at cross-purposes with one
another so Billy Graham's death is a
reminder that building the social fabric
is one of the chief roles of religion
particularly American religion Billy
Graham's life is pretty amazing every
year since 1955 grandmas on galip's list
of most admired men and women according
to Hank Barry and over the Daily wire
his fierce hatred of segregation meant
churches had to integrate for his
revivals as far back as 1953 when in a
revival in Jackson Mississippi
uh sure set up ropes to segregate the
races Graeme asked for the ropes to be
removed when the usher refused Graham
took them down himself and told all the
people to sit where they wanted at a
Madison Square revival in 1957 he
invited Martin Luther King to preach
together as King said quote had it not
been for the ministry of my good friend
dr. Billy Graham my work in the civil
rights movement would not have been
successful at it as it has been Graham
often paid the bill the Bay
and finds that King received when he was
in jail is again one of the lies about
the civil rights movement he was pushed
by a bunch of atheist is pushed by a
bunch of religious leaders dr. Martin
Luther King was a reverend Reverend
Billy Graham was a reverend he was born
November 7th 1918 the oldest of four
children born to Morrow coffee and
William Franklin Graham senior he grew
up on a dairy farm near Charlotte North
Carolina as a child he loved to read
books and in 1933 his father forced him
and his sister to drink beer until they
got sick which prompted both children
who swore off alcohol and drugs for the
rest of their lives children were raised
differently back in 1933 the next year
having seen the evangelist Mordecai ham
he was converted by him he went to Bob
Jones College in Tennessee where who's
almost expelled but Jones told him quote
at best all you could announce would be
a poor country Baptist preacher
somewhere out in the sticks
you have a voice that pulls God can use
that voice of yours he can use it
mightily and so Graham transferred to
Florida Bible Institute he preached his
first sermon at Bostwick Baptist Church
in 1937 and became a national figure in
1949 when he held a series of revivals
in LA and had circus tents erected in
the parking lot which led to national
media coverage and he hosted TV of
course from 1947 until 2005 it's
worthwhile paying honored to a man who
did a lot more good than he did bad in
this world built Reverend Billy Graham
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like I've started the show
Longmire which has been recommended to
me on Netflix is it the best show I've
ever seen no I mean I've only seen the
pilot episode I tend to like I tend to
like less episodic shows where you don't
wrap up a plot in one episode but it is
well written and it is kind of taciturn
Western so I love westerns you put on
the cowboy hat and you and you have a
guy speaking in short phrases with with
fun profundity and I'm into it so that's
what Longmire is so check out Longmire
he's a little bit of preview don't
matter if you're in the city or the
country
crime don't change there are always
suspects what about the girl move around
some folks like you can't find it I
asked you a very simple question and
there are two types of people that like
to kill from a distance cowards and pros
there are always victims afraid I have
some very bad news okay so it's that
kind of show right if you like that kind
of voice you like that kind of show it's
pretty simple so you can check out
Longmire
over at Netflix where it is now
available okay other things that I like
so nikki Haley I gave a speech yesterday
at the UN the Mahmoud Abbas the
Palestinian dictator because he is now
in the what 17 let's see I think he's
elected 2005 so he is now in the
thirteenth year of a four-year tenure so
that's exciting
he had told nikki Haley are you an
ambassador - shut up she came out
yesterday firing again nikki Haley at
the UN is my spirit animal so here she
is I sit here today offering the
outstretched hand of the United States
to the Palestinian people in the cause
of peace we are fully prepared to look
to a future of prosperity and
coexistence
we welcome you as the leader of the
Palestinian people here today but I will
decline the advice I was recently given
by your top negotiator Saeb Erekat
I will not shut up rather I will
respectfully speak some hard truths okay
love it
nikki Haley doing yeoman's work over at
the UN so that is fantastic stuff nikki
Haley is the best okay a quick thing
that I hate
so Alyssa Milano came out and and
tweeted about the Second Amendment and
what she tweeted about the Second
Amendment was a particularly stupid
thing so when she tweeted out was it
said also pushy said also popular in
1791 the year the Second Amendment was
adopted and then it's a list of things
slavery the three-fifths compromise
bloodletting LED paints being literally
owned by her husband cholera smallpox
typhus dying in childbirth a lot using
chamber pots unsanitary surgical
procedures traveling by horse or foot
dying at the age of 40 things change
y'all we can do better
hey I wasn't aware that smallpox was
actually popular in 1791 as a people had
smallpox parties they got together and
they said oh you got that hot smallpox
passing on man just hand me the smallpox
dying in childbirth also not aware that
that was supremely popular in 1791 I
think people saw that as bad in 1791
even slavery which was popular in
certain parts of the United States and
1791 was certainly not popular in
certain other parts of the United States
in 1791 but if you're going to talk
about things that are in the
Constitution of the United States which
seems to me closer than smallpox to
resemblance to the Second Amendment try
the First Amendment other things that
were popular on in 1791 freedom of
religion freedom of speech no quartering
of troops no illegal search and seizures
a right to a jury trial a right against
a right against a torturer right these
were things that were pretty popular in
1791 it turns out cuz they're in that
same document you stupid idiot so that
again there's it there's a notion on the
left that all of time began with their
birth I remember the Barack Obama said
something about how Bill Ayers what Bill
Ayers did before he met Bill Ayers was
irrelevant because Bill Ayers basically
didn't exist as a human right Billy
Ayers did all this stuff when I was a
kid okay so what so what the world
didn't start turning when you were born
but folks on the Left seemed to start
seem to think that all of the good
things in life began just spontaneously
when they were born or discovered them
and that they never pre-existed that the
same ideology the same philosophy that
brought you freedom of speech and
freedom of religion brought you the
right to keep and bear arms they were
part and parcel of the same philosophy
as far as the the notion that
three-fifths compromise was some sort of
ideological with some sort of
ideological commitment to the non
peoplehood of black people that's idiocy
if you look at the actual negotiations
over the three-fifths compromise which
is a bad provision of the Constitution
the reason that it is in the
Constitution is because it was there to
prove
a worst provision of the Constitution
which would have been counting black
people as full people for purposes of
voting but counting them as property for
purposes of not being able to actually
vote or do anything that's what the
South wanted the South wanted slave
owners wanted that if there were a bunch
of black folks were living in slavery in
South Carolina for purposes of
representation in the Congress for South
Carolina black folks would be counted as
people but they would not be able to
vote they would still be considered
property and the North said no we're not
going to do that you don't get to count
black people as full people excuse me
because it's skews the representative
sample if the North had came to that and
said sure black people are full people
for purposes of representation but not
people for purposes of property guess
what slavery would have lasted longer
because the South would have had more
votes in the Congress but again
knowledge and historical and historical
learning are apparently somehow there a
lot of folks on the Left who are
allergic to them they kill a lot of the
narratives they love so much alrighty so
we'll be back here tomorrow from CPAC
I'm speaking at CPAC and I will have I
promised some notes on CPAC but I ran
out of time again today I'll have some
notes on CPAC C PAC apparantly quick
note just ban they just got rid of Jim
Hoffs is one of the speakers over to
Gateway pundit because Jim Hoffs had
been tweeting out stupidities about the
the school shooting victims in parkland
I think that is perfectly appropriate as
far as Mary and lepen who's been invited
I'm not sure why Marian lepen is
representative of conservatism I didn't
book her I wouldn't have booked her that
said I'm more than happy to speak to the
thousands of students who are going to
hear about some real conservatism and
that's an opportunity I look forward to
having tomorrow at CPAC so if you're at
CPAC in the Washington DC area show up
and I'll see you there I'm Ben Shapiro
this the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alec singhara audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018